thank you all so much for being here
like this is kind of crazy because I've
told the story probably 45 million times
at this point but vlog university was
just a little youtube show that I made
over ten years ago I bought the domain I
squatted on the Twitter and the
Instagram I had it all for so long and
then when we were thinking about this
conference we were like what could we
call it I said well I've had this domain
for 10 years why don't we put it to use
and we're like this is so perfect and
this child saw me and she turned to her
mom and she's like mommy mommy mommy
that man's leg fell off
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry I'm heading to Nikki Sun session
has already started so we're gonna kind
of sneak in she's talking about choosing
the right camera for the job
[Music]
we're setting up for my panel now it's
gonna be talking about little production
you guys have seen me post tons of
videos about this but now I had to
condense everything that I know into a
one-hour kind of presentation I don't
really do this stuff that often so
making like a keynote and a presentation
to try to like teach people stuff was a
whole nother experience but I'm really
excited to share I think I brought too
much stuff because I feel like there are
people that you can reach on every
platform so it's like never just miss
snapchat just because you think well my
audience isn't there people are on
pretty much everything which was my
initial kind of entrance into the space
[Music]
I survived I did it everyone had great
questions we had a little giveaway of
the DJI Osmo so thank you DDI for giving
me one of those to give away but I think
it went well
do you be my video okay you eat you all
the way from Brazil yes all the way for
those purple University that is so cool
like I was like I was gonna cry like
that's so cool like you know so much I
just hope that you can leave here
inspired and learn some stuff to channel
what's your channel it's a very no
alvey's english thank you so much okay
so we're going to be doing some
giveaways this is the VIP lunch so I'm
getting to go around and chat with
everybody so it's like just say hi I
want to let you guys meet Emily Emily I
think I mean I know a lot of you guys
watch my videos but I think she could
quite possibly rival some of you for the
biggest fan do you want to say hi to my
blog this is Emily I was just saying
that some people say like there's my
biggest fan but I was like I think that
Emily might be the winner
thank you so much for coming something
for you you did yes so me and my friends
we I wanted internet friends and I met
because of you and so we've sent me
messages and stuff so I need you like a
little scrapbook oh my gosh this is so
cool oh look at little baby Bryn oh my
gosh this is amazing oh wow read okay
I'm gonna have to do some reading this
is so oh my gosh yeah this is amazing oh
my gosh I'm gonna read all of this okay
Rockman not tonight but tomorrow after
vlog university i can reminisce this is
so amazing thank you oh my god doesn't
mean so much to me video
for Maddy Maddy has a gift
yeah
[Music]
so what's happening right now is we are
doing a four person shoot using double
take you guys may have seen Jenna and I
make this video about this
so we're recording this so yeah we're
recording right now feels weird being
this close yeah I don't know if I should
look at the camera are you guys like
this is so crazy this is the first
actually double take four-way interview
here this is a pretty impressive I'm
impressed
this is a good mobile ring hi Francesca
hi Justine oh my goodness Laura vlog
University right now if you haven't been
able to tell from this entire video when
we're about to do a session where
Francesca doesn't make up I'm Francesca
she's Francesca we've been working
together for a very long time I think a
decade they apply it's gonna be doing a
session here I'm gonna go take my makeup
off and then she's gonna put some more
makeup back on and then we're gonna
carry on carry on carry huh I wasn't
trying to think of a song but I couldn't
this is gonna look like a two behind
scenes editing Connors on edit duty I'm
taking my makeup off for my next session
it's looking so good I don't know what
that changed but here it is so good so
good oh my gosh it's perfect it's so
good it's so gonna love it yes I love it
I like to just take this brush I pinch
it pinch it and then I just run it
across the crease like that
[Music]
Oh where'd all this stuff come from we
have a lot of amazing sponsors that made
this Expo night possible but first we're
gonna stop by Jovi you know that I love
Jovi and they have a lot of awesome
things I mentioned you guys today oh yes
because I wanted to bring it but I could
not find it in my I do this is like the
perfect starter kit of course I can't be
trusted I can't be trusted okay hold on
hello hello
hi how's it going so I just got one of
these and I'm really excited to test it
out I love that it could work with iOS
for my iPad
they were definitely adding this to my
mobile kid hi Justine I'm sorry I didn't
mean to sneak up I was just getting
bigger
oh we got to say hi to black magic hello
oh my gosh this is this is a rig okay so
I think this is probably something that
we're going to need to start vlogging
with what do you think Jake Tyler how's
the blog oh yeah no yes I think so I
think so
here's sermonic as well so cool
you get the federal gimbal which also
passes some audio and this microphone
yes retro tripod yet the V Mike mini and
you get a full on camera mount that you
can use with your mobile device I love
this
well let's go
that's the blink system but I don't have
this little guy oh this go with my phone
this is what I needed this morning
during my talk I was talking about how I
want it yes and then with the
transmitters you already have you can
sync the transmitters you already have
right to this thank you thank you for
being here okay we've gotten an light up
next and these things we've been using
non-stop the tube lights you guys saw me
post about our own Instagram photo I'm
just enjoying all of the light
[Music]
day one I can't believe it ready for day
two I am I'm gonna go home and go to bed
right now are you gonna get some sleep
yes I will well as soon as I lay down I
fall asleep like it's just it's game
over
thank you so much again tomorrow
hi hi Oh what kind of geared you guys
bring today so we got to show you
there's a button they can shoot you
yeah that's cool it's blue true nice
yeah this is awesome oh my gosh push the
side one maybe you could talk to that
I'm sold
[Music]
[Applause]
and that is a wrap on day one of log
view I had so much fun I met so many
amazing people and one of the best
pieces feedback that I got is everyone
had so much fun in the classes and they
learned a lot and they are inspired that
is exactly what I wanted from this event
and it happened and we still have a
whole nother day so thank you guys for
watching thank you to everyone who came
here and that's that's a wrap on day one
bye
[Music]